Ryan klechner is an attorney and former
Army Ranger he joins us to assess all of
this Ryan thank you so much for coming
on so when you take these people
seriously and I think we probably should
since they have more power than most of
us do what they're suggesting is
disarming a country that owns billions
of rounds of ammunition 400 million
Firearms what they're calling for is a
totalitarian state and Civil War
you're absolutely right because who's
going to be going to try to collect
these who's going to be actually
effectuating these policies I mean
I say that when a politician tells you
you don't need a gun it's time to get a
gun and these comparisons we're making
to these other countries that are
largely homogeneous mostly isolated
countries that don't have porous borders
like we do where drugs and crime are
just flowing across freely are able to
effectuate some sort of gun control but
it still doesn't help gun violence might
go down but I'm not a believer that gun
violence is the only bad thing I think
all violent crime is bad and I actually
have an article on Sean Davis's the
Federalist website about how violent
crime in Australia has actually
increased ever since they took away
people's ability to defend themselves
well crime by the government has
increased dramatically I mean the
Australian government the authoritarian
Australian government put people in
concentration camps for violating their
non-scientific coveted rules so I mean
civilians are not the only people who
commit crimes the biggest crimes are
always committed by the government
always
yes and and every bad government that we
look at in history what's one of the
things they did first they take away the
gun see the problem is too is
I am tired of being painted even by
family members or people that I know as
someone that doesn't think these mass
shootings are horrible I think they are
so horrible that I think my ideas and
ideas that show that we shouldn't have
disarmed schools we should actually
protect our children are so much better
at saving these lives that's why it's so
important to me rushing to try and get
rid of guns to keep someone from doing
something horrible like this it's the
same as a little Banning fentanyl we
have 100 ban on fentanyl in this country
is it doing a whole lot of good no it's
everywhere and matter of fact think of
the people that are in control of these
drugs that are 100 banned Zero Tolerance
100 banned those people that disregard
the laws we call them criminals they're
the ones that would have the guns this
is a horrible idea it's not going to
make anyone safer it's it's bad all
around
well if we want to stop murders to find
out why murder murderers commit murder
and we should take a look at this
Manifesto and if the murderer from
Monday says I'm committing this mass
shooting because Tennessee has lacks gun
laws then let's have that conversation
but I suspect that's not what it says
Ryan collector great so one AR-15 was
used for evil one was used for good
thanks well exactly subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight